hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me so dune seemed to have totally been
the success that warner brothers wanted
and made enough money at the box office
is approaching 300 million dollars
it was successful on hbo max and
critically people loved it and part 2
has already been green lit but there is
one other thing that i was thinking
about and i've been talking about that i
don't know if other people have been
talking about is that what happens when
dune blows up and it's the next big
thing
everyone wants to make their own dune it
happened with game of thrones it
happened with lord of the rings and now
it's happening with science fiction with
dune because hyperion is being adapted
now if you don't know hyperion by dan
simmons is one of the best science
fiction books that i personally have
ever read the fall of hyperion the
follow-up book is also really good
there's two extra books and demian and
rhizobium they're a little bit different
but still pretty good i would say but
hyperion itself is a phenomenal science
fiction book and the world that appears
in the science fiction book is just
weird and expansive and definitely a bit
doom inspired
and i've just been really excited to
cover it on my channel over the last few
years
now it's official hyperion
is being adapted and it's moving forward
now if you didn't know the rights to
hyperion were actually in the hands of
sci-fi the sci-fi channel for a while
which like was kind of like oh my god
they will not make a good hyperion like
the sci-fi channel maybe like
20 years ago when the dune mini series
came out and then the children of doom
mini series came out they could have
maybe thought about making a high period
mini series but even probably not even
then
certainly not now
but the rights have actually moved from
tv sci-fi channel to warner brothers and
oscar winner graham king is attached to
produce this movie also bradley cooper
is also attached to this film to some
degree uh because the film is launching
under his new production banner which is
associated with warner brothers i don't
know how all of this business stuff
works but bradley cooper is also somehow
attached to this movie but he won't be
in the movie or really like producing it
on any real level but he is attached to
it now emmy winner tom spezzly is also
attached to this production he is known
for the watchmen show on hbo which was
pretty good except for like right at the
end in my opinion which you know is more
david lindelof's fault because lost
obviously it has also been announced
that haley king will executive produce
this adaptation
now
it is very very very very early on of
course it has not been stated whether or
not this will be a show
or a miniseries or a movie
if i had to put my two cents in i would
say definitely go the show route
definitely 100
please do a show uh do not make this
into a movie put this on
hbo max as a 10 episode thing for season
one and then you can do ten more
episodes for
book two and then maybe do continue into
the other ones but
the structure of hyperion especially
that first book lends itself
so well
so well to a series because you have all
of these characters coming together and
interacting with each other and telling
stories about how they got up into that
point so each chapter is kind of like a
retelling of like that person's past up
until that point and i think that would
really lend itself
to a tv show where you can really have
time to sit with these characters and
sit with the world because if we put
this into a movie we try to cram this
all into a movie the giant hyperion
series it's not gonna go well it's not
gonna go well i know that when something
like doing is successful like the
temptation is like let's do it exactly
like they did it let's do a big part one
and then do a part two maybe a part
three it's no hyperion we already have
the format that works best for this type
of story it's a mini series or a tv show
so that is just my two cents other than
that i am so so so freaking excited for
the hyperion tv show i'll be excited if
it turns out to be a movie too i just
would be a little bit more worried about
it like how they're gonna squeeze all of
that
into just one movie because there's so
much to it and you learn so much about
the world through each of these
characters stories and you learn so much
about like the hegemony of man and then
there are the sentient ai and the techno
core that have their own society and we
don't know what they're up to so there's
just a lot of really really interesting
things in the hyperion series that we
need to spend time in and if it's a
movie they're just going to blow right
past him so like give me that tv show
let's like slow it down a bit and i'm so
excited
and if you are not at all familiar with
hyperion check out my hyperion explained
in five minutes video i also have
countless other videos on hyperion um
explaining various aspects of the lore
and their society kind of like i have
with dune and foundation and various
other series on this channel you guys
know the drill so this is exciting i
hope everybody's ready for the new
hyperion thing that's coming
and make sure you like and subscribe for
more quiz ideas peace guys
[Music]
you